أريد فقط أن أتعمق
قليلاً لمشاهدينا
الذين ربما يكونون أقل
إلمامًا بالطريقة التي
يعمل
بها المجتمع الأردني وهذا أمر مهم
، حيث تم اعتقال بعض أفراد قبيلة عائلتك
بسبب هذا
الانقلاب المزعوم ، وكثير منهم يعملون في
منزل الأمير حمزة.
مكتب قبيلة المجالي لها
نفوذ في الأردن العديد من أفرادها
مثلك ألقوا خطبة في مناصب بارزة
في الحكومة والجيش في
بيان الأسبوع الماضي
وصفت قبيلتك الاعتقالات بأنها
غير مشروعة
والحدث بأنه يوم أسود في تاريخ الأردن.
شارك هذا الاعتقاد
يا سيدتي ، دعني أجيب على الجزء الثاني
أولاً ، سأجيب على الجزء الثاني
أولاً ، حيث
يمكن لأي شخص أن يخرج الآن ويدعي
أنهم يتحدثون طوال الوقت
وهذا غير صحيح ، ولا أقول إنه
كان هناك  يتحدث عدد لا بأس
به ولكن ليس القبيلة
التي تتحدث عنها
أكثر من 23 24000 شخص تعرفهم عندما
يخرج 50 شخصًا يأتي 100 شخص
لا يفعلون ذلك
يمثلون طوال الوقت ، لذا من المحتمل أن يكون بعضهم
من الأشخاص المتضررين وأنا
أتعاطف معهم
ولكن لا ينبغي أن نبالغ في
الأمر ، لذلك هذا هو رقم واحد
ننتقل إلى الرقم الثاني وقد
ذكرت
أن عضوين من الأغلبية  القبائل التي
تم اعتقالها ،
كان أحدهم هو القائد السابق الذي كان رئيس
الأمن لصاحب السمو الملكي
والآخر لا أعرفه.
العائلة المالكة بدءًا من
جلالة الملك
وصولاً إلى الأسفل يتم الترحيب بهم في
كل قبيلة
في الأردن ، لدينا
نهج غير غربي غريب جدًا تجاه رئيس
دولتنا ،
فنحن لا ننظر إليهم على أنهم ملك فقط نحن
ننظر إليهم
بصفتي رب عائلة ، لذا فإن جميع
القبائل في الأردن هي عائلة
صاحب الجلالة الملك وجميع أفراد
العائلة المالكة ،
وجميع أفراد العائلة المالكة
مرحب بهم ،
وكل أسرة ليست
حصرية لهذه العائلة.  ibe
أو في وقت آخر وعلى العكس
لا توجد قبيلة
حصرية للعائلة المالكة
فنحن أمة مبنية
على دساتير
وقوانين وهناك
مؤسسات دستورية
تحكم آلية
ذلك ونحن ننظر إلى العرش في
مؤسسة  العرش
هو العمود الفقري لاستقرار
الأردن وتقدّم الأردن إلى الأمام
ونحن جميعًا جسد واحد يتحرك معًا
ليس لدينا تشيشولم ليس لدينا صدع
في المجتمع ، هناك أصوات هنا
وهناك وكما ذكرت هنا
الهاشتاغ  هناك
ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بأمن الأمة وأمن المملكة الأردنية الهاشمية ، فإن جميع الأردنيين
هم صوت واحد
خلف قائدنا الذي يمتلك جلالة
الملك الحسين
وولي العهد من سموهم
أنفسهم
القصر يصفون هذا الأمر بأنه
أم شقاق عائلي وأنا
فقط أتساءل ما إذا كنت تعتقد
أنه أكثر من ذلك ، سواء كان
هذا انقلابًا مزعومًا ، أصدر الملك
بيانًا يقول فيه أن الأمير ها  mza في
المنزل في رعايتي ، وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مليئة بالأسئلة وعلامات التصنيف
المحيطة بمكان وجوده ، لذا هل يمكنك
إخبارنا بمكان وجوده في الوقت الحالي ،
فأنا لست على دراية
بمثل هذه المعلومات ولكن
يمكنني تأكيد ما يصل إلى 99
إذا لم يكن كذلك  ما يقرب من 100 في المائة أيضًا
أن صاحب السمو الملكي موجود في منزله
مع عائلته والتي بالمناسبة على بعد
حوالي
400 متر فقط من مكان إقامة جلالة الملك ،
يعيشون في مجمع واحد وهو
موجود هناك وأعتقد أن كل الهاشتاقات
وكل ما هو عليه  ليس هناك
ما هو غير صحيح
فهو في رعاية جلالة
الملك
ينسى الناس أحيانًا أنه
شقيق جلالة الملك أعني
، وإذا كان هناك
أي فكر آخر في أدوات مختلفة
لاستخدامها ،
فلن يظهر ذلك على أي
حال  ظهرت على السطح
رسميًا ، وظهرت من خلال
سطحها آسفًا من خلال مؤتمر صحفي
عقده نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجية
، ثم تلاه
اجتماع مع شيوخ الأسرة
برئاسة صاحب السمو الملكي.  سمو أمير
الحسن مرساة جلالة
الملك
وتم حل الأمر
هناك ثم قام الأمير الإسرائيلي البغيض
حمزة
بالتوقيع على ورقة يلتزم بها
لجلالته وهو تحت أمر جلالته
وسيستمر في عيش حياته
هؤلاء.  هي حقائق